Oui, monsieur le président, chers collègues,
je crois que quand on parle d'Ame,
il faut rappeler quelques points.
Euh. À commencer que 1 tiers des Français
ont déjà renoncé à des soins,
faute de moyens,
15/2 déclare peiner à se soigner,
que le gouvernement, d'ailleurs,
euh, ces dernières années,
a continué à diminuer le remboursement
des soins pour les français.
Pendant ce temps-là, le nombre de bénéficiaires de la ML,
lui, il augmente,
vous l'avez dit, mais de ce ministre, il augmente
forcément à proportion de
de l'augmentation de l'immigration qui touche le pays.
82% d'augmentation,
euh, ces 10 dernières années, c'est considérable.
Pour deux-mille-vingt-quatre, la mme coûtera
1,2000000000 d'euros au français.
C'est 1 régime, d'ailleurs qui est 1 exception en Europe.
Et si je me félicite qu'au Sénat,
et bien, il y ait eu la suppression de la eme,
au profit de la création d'une aide médicale d'urgence,
comme le propose Marine Le Pen,
depuis de très nombreuses années,
je regrette qu'ici, la majorité,
euh. Y compris la gauche évidemment,
euh. Et bien
réintroduise, ou tente en tout cas de réintroduire,
euh, ce dispositif tout à l'heure